in questo momento storico in cui il
coronavirus ci contagia gli empi nostri
ospedali nelle nostre sale di
rianimazione i nostri cimiteri ecco io
mi auguro una sola cosa che tutti quanti
possiamo essere contagiati ma da un
minimo di informazione una frase simile
a dice jonathan bazzi nel suo libro
febbre vedevano frase mi ha sempre fatto
pensare
la prima segnalazione di questa specie
di polpetta con l'evento è stata fatta
nel 2019 a dicembre focolaio one cina
8.662 chilometri di aereo da roma poco
più di 10.000 km se volessimo farla in
macchina presente parliamo di giorni di
viaggio se volessimo farcela piedi
sarebbero settimane la cina un posto che
non ci appartiene una cultura distante
dalla nostra
del resto non le indossiamo ogni giorno
non ci nutriamo ogni giorno non la
mettiamo i piedi non la portiamo con noi
e non ci permette di catturare momenti
tramite delle foto o anche semplicemente
rimanere in contatto col mondo grazie a
questo ci metto io del resto due ore a
fare le scale figura di st polpetta con
le ventose fa fare tutti sti km arrivare
fino a me ma è fattibile e poi la cosa
positiva è che era riconoscibile perché
questo virus dagli occhi a mandorla no
non era una polpetta con le ventose
c'era poco un cinese
finché poi non ho letto le notizie il
primo caso in italia di coronavirus è
infatti un italiano io subito me lo sono
chiesto in che senso tipo c'è un cinese
travestito italiano cioè si sa che i
cinesi entrano tipo in 20 in una cabina
telefonica
ecco magari uno solo riesce a entrare
nello stomaco di un italiano è stato
fatto tutto sto casino sui cinesi e alla
fine a fotterci e un italiano
per di più del nord che almeno fosse
stato non lo so pugliese potevamo
prenderci a cui [ __ ] è invece il 9 el
11 marzo il 2020 leggo testuali parole
scusate ci vengono comunicate le misure
urgenti in materia di contenimento e
gestione dell'emergenza epidemiologica
da cupid 19 io le prime sereno chiedevo
io con fissato il soffitto diciamo come
cazzo ha fatto questo virus a fotterci
tutti quanti in questo modo ho sentito
il mio nonno a dire a mio fratello
tranquillo gabryele vai dal macellaio
senza problemi perché un brav'uomo un
brav'uomo il macellaio
ho sentito anche dire cose tipo ma siamo
amici ma ci conosciamo vabbè ma è uno di
famiglia
ed è lì che ho capito una cosa
importante che il virus è invece una
polpetta con le ventose alla con noi
ne frega un cazzo dei rapporti delle
persone non gliene frega niente se
questa si fa dicono qualcuno non è che
tutte quelle braccine sono per fare o
attento fermate aspetta controlla no con
le braccine sono lì proprio per piatte
stando ai dati del 17 marzo del 2020
siamo arrivati a 2500 tre persone che
hanno perso la vita per colpa del
coronavirus stanno parlando di
situazioni tragiche in alcuni momenti
bare vuote che non possono ancora essere
riempite benché meno sepolte ci aspetta
il 3 aprile per poter piangere fare un
funerale un tè aprile poi del tutto
aleatorio perché naturalmente la gente
continua a uscire di casa e non sto
parlando di persone che escono per
andare al lavoro per andare in farmacia
a fare la spesa a portare il cane per
motivi di salute
no alcune persone ancora escono per i
cazzi propri leggo di nuovi dati 20
6.062 le persone positive al tampone ad
oggi di queste 12 mila 894 ricoverate
2060 in terapia intensiva e alcuni
speciali sono così pieni che non possono
più prendere malati e i malati sono
costretti a rimanere a casa e alcuni di
noi
nonostante tutto continuano a farsi i
cazzi loro continuano a farsi i cazzi
loro
scusa ma a rimanere a casa in che senso
nel senso che devi rimanere a casa ho
capito sì ma non è chiaro il decreto no
infatti non è chiaro è chiarissimo è
lampante il decreto o capitano come
possiamo sopravvivere in compagnia con
noi stessi cazzi tuoi in che senso cazzi
tuoi nel senso che se tu un esame di
coscienza contro sei già fatto bene
inizia adesso perché c'è un sacco di
tempo e potrebbe anche non bastardi
quindi mettete lavoro che ci hai tanto
da recuperare ma non ha fatto il secondo
io ho letto su www.ilfattoquotidiano.it
e c'è tutto un complotto dei poteri
forti perché noi abbiamo il vita in
italia
no io invece ho letto su bachi da seta e
acquasanta che tu puoi uscire di casa
senza problemi importante che saltelli
su una sola gamba e con un condor
imbalsamato sotto il braccio nora gam e
la moglie dell'amico del tizio che
lavora al maneggio di cicciolina ci
avete presente ecco mi ha detto che il
trisavolo medico le apparso in sogno e
le ha detto che 7 infine un limone in
culo passa la paura perché combatte la
malattia eviti il contagio signori vi
chiedo scusa
alzo le mani perché ora non saprò che la
scienza fosse un parere
le dessero su google anzi torno subito a
legare i cessi degli autogrill perché
chi pensavate che gli desse politiche
c'è gente con la quale ha dovuto pure
litigare nel momento in cui ho detto
cercate rimanere a casa perché perché
sono costretti ad andare al lavoro
gente che mi ha detto meno paghi tu lo
stipendio no premio nobel non te lo pago
io e ovvio che se devi andare al lavoro
ci devi andare io ora capisco lo stress
capisco la paura ma se vogliamo allora
proseguire con questa politica del cazzo
del chi sta peggio pensiamo a tutte le
persone che non possono lavorare gente
che è stata mandata a casa dall'oggi al
domani
gente che non può nemmeno a lamentarsi
delle tre ore di fila che si aprano
supermercato perché non sa nemmeno come
pagarsi la spesa pensiamo agli italiani
che sono rimasti all'estero che mi
scrivono e che non riescono a tornare
non sanno più a chi chiedere aiuto sono
persone bloccate fuori che si sentono
abbandonati si sentono costrette ad
affrontare una pandemia che manco
conoscono all'interno di un posto nel
quale non si sentono sicuri opposti che
prendono delle misure sanitarie al
limite della follia ma non voglio
nemmeno entrare in quell argomento
insieme un sacco di persone che ogni
giorno vengono paralizzati dalla paura
dagli attacchi di panico incitati
completamente dalle proprie solitudini
perché questo virus non sta prendendo
solamente i polmoni purtroppo spesso sta
prendendo anche il cuore in maniera
fosse diversa persone che fanno dei
sacrifici mentre dall'altra parte ci
stanno persone che si fanno i cazzi loro
ho sentito gente che ha il coraggio di
dire eh ma tanto il virus prende
solamente i vecchi sono cazzi loro a
perché tu sei nato sotto un cavolo cioè
tu non hai parenti se come adamo senato
fatto e finito solo che invece di
toglierti agosto data ha tolto il lobo
frontale quando ti ha creato ecco e
comunque se l'unica no se ti preoccupa
il tuo culo sappi che ci stanno dei
ragazzi in ospedali attaccati e
respiratori e con cui visto che ci tengo
a te posso suggerirvi una cosa fino a di
un pochino di ossigeno al cervello
farebbe bene anche atteggiata adesso il
problema è che noi capiamo solamente
quando ci bruciamo siamo come i bambini
che devono per forza mettere le dita
nella presa per capire che si fanno male
e che forse con un po di rimpianto
avrebbero dovuto ascoltare la mamma e
poi ci siamo noi noi che per carità
fermi non ci sappiamo stare in casa ci
rompiamo i [ __ ] perché si la vita ce
l'abbiamo dentro c bastiano vogliamo
farla esplodere st vita fuori una volta
per tutte anche io che sono un
misantropo voglio vedere la gente
improvvisamente io che da solo mi carico
per poter stare insieme
noi che distanti
cuciniamo noi che cantiamo noi che una
volta per tutte grazie al cielo diamo un
senso vero
a questi social noi che l'abbiamo capito
che questo virus è una polpetta con le
ventose noi che sappiamo che non ha un
senso che questa vita non ha un senso
perché noi ci diamo un senso l'uno con
l'altro perché andrà bene andrà bene
grazie al nostro impegno ma soprattutto
grazie a quello dei medici che in questo
periodo stanno venendo letteralmente
piegati dal lavoro piegati dalla fatica
professionisti stanno venendo
schiacciati dalla noncuranza del cui le
persone persone che non riesco a
prendere sul serio se stessi figuriamoci
gli altri
noi che lavoriamo un i social possiamo
provare a mandare dei messaggi possiamo
cercare intrattenere le persone spesso
anche magari con la paura di dire
qualcosa è sbagliato possiamo cercare di
alleggerire la nostra la vostra
solitudine quei mezzi che abbiamo ma in
questo momento storico è la scienza il
regista di questo film
noi siamo gli attori possiamo cercare di
aiutarla a salvare st pellicola de merda
in tanti stiamo dimostrando unione forza
amore intelligenza genio e per ogni
persona che infanga il nome del nostro
paese ci sono già 10 pronte a pulire a
farmi scoprire il cuore di orgoglio gli
orgogli o per tutti quanti noi io
sinceramente non so se alla fine di
tutto questo vinceremo una statuetta
non so è forse un po dubito che alla
fine di tutto questo impareremo qualcosa
veramente da questa esperienza qualcosa
che ci rimanga nel tempo
non so se nel nostro discorso di
accettazione di remo siamo cambiati
abbiamo capito dubito si riceve il tempo
fuori tutte le ferite rio credo che
cancelli anche un sacco insegnamenti una
cosa però è sicura la terra sta
prendendo una boccata d'aria da noi ed è
assurdo vedere come anche se ci fermiamo
lei non smette di girare la primavera si
sveglia il sole si fa sempre più lento
nel cielo utili si ricordiamocelo
indispensabili ma perché la butto lì e
magari anche noi eravamo diventati per
la terra sempre meno simili a un uomo è
sempre più simile a una polpetta con le
ventose andrà tutto bene ragazzi